une histoire passée.
Marie-Josée Paquette-Com
- Une livraison d'urgence...
- Ottawa n'a plus de choix
devant la pénurie d'ibuprofène
et d'acétaminophène pour
enfants. Il se tourne vers
l'étranger : un million
de bouteilles d'analgésique
seront importées. Les 10 usines
canadiennes de production de
ces produits pharmaceutiques
ne fournissent plus.
La production nationale
est normalement de
5 à 6000 unités par mois.
Dr MARC BERTHIAUME, Santé Canada
- Les fabricants ont augmenté
leur production pour atteindre
des niveaux records, mais la
demande a continué de croître
et a grandement dépassé l'offre.
- Les premières quantités
seront livrées aux hôpitaux
pédiatriques. Partout au pays,
leurs urgences débordent
d'enfants atteints
de virus respiratoires.
Dans la capitale nationale,
une deuxième unité temporaire
de soins intensifs sera créée.
En attendant, on transfert
certains enfants malades dans
les hôpitaux de Kingston, situés
à plus de deux heures d'Ottawa.
ALEX MUNTER, chef direction
Centre hosp. enfants, Ontario
- On est en train de planifier,
si nécessaire, l'ouverture
d'encore plus de lits.
- Incroyablement
irresponsabl
- Pour l'opposition,
cette solution ne viendra pas
à bout de la pénurie.
PETER JULIAN, leader en Chambre
du Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Ilququququ'on soit capable
de produire des médicaments
ici au Canada. Le gouvernement
n'a rien fait là-dessus.
Le gouvernement semble réagir
trop tard.SISISISIMON-PIERRE SA,
député bloquiste Saint-Hyacinthe
- Un million de bouteilles...
reste à voir pour la grandeur
du Canada d'un océan à
l'autre... reste à voir si
ça va suffire.
LAILA GOODRIDGE, députée
conserv. Fort McMurray-Cold Lake
- Ils sont toujours vagues
dans leur réplique :
"Dans les semaines prochaines,
la semaine prochaine",
des choses comme ça.
Mais jamais ils nous donnent
une date. Les parents,
ils veulent une date.
- Le gouvernement promet
que  d'ici 2 à 3 semaines,
les parents verront de nouveau
des tablettes pleines à
la pharmacie. Il les invite
à ne pas acheter plus de
produits qu'il b b b b besoin,
car la pénurie n'est pas prête
de se résorber.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Ottaw